dude where's my car is I've always said
it was a funny movie but it had one of
the greatest titles of all time you and
ashton kutcher now ashton was on the
show not too long ago and he said
there's a sequel floating around a
script what are your favourite films
right yeah yeah I stood right up there
and he said that and this is not a joke
he said the title of it is seriously
dude where it's my car I thought that
was brilliant you have to do the movie
if the script sucked I would still do it
just because the title yeah I mean it's
genius Denzel Washington can't say the
he did seriously dude was my car on his
resume right he can't but I could it's
tearing him apart your dog is this right
your dog's name is his name's dude your
dog's name is dude it just seemed
fitting yeah but he gets I don't know if
it came from the movie it might have but
but yeah he gets a little confused
though because I call everybody dude
right so just so for a while like the
first five years he's like yeah he took
me but he's kind of gotten used to it
now yeah yeah well it you and I've
noticed that over the years is that you
use just as yourself you use dude
constantly so I would think yeah your
dog would be schizophrenic at this
you're yeah you're on the phone like
dude I'm gonna break your head your dogs
just cowering in the corner
you